Okay.
And your... wait.
And your singer for tonight...
The one... the freakiest... presenting...
Mint Phantom!
The crowd goes wild!
Nervous!
I tried to dress up a little bit for the theme today, so...
Don't make fun of me, okay?
I know that I look like I'm going to my high school dance, okay?
I know!
I try.
Okay, true story.
Actually, there was a whole lot of things that...
Let me just... let me just get it over with.
I'm ripping up the band-aid!
I...
I have stories, okay?
Okay, okay.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Okay, let me explain.
So, I don't know how other YouTubers do it.
I tried to put on new clothes and I think my ghost body rejected them.
And so...
Also...
True story, my washing machine broke yesterday.
And I...
I was like, the other clothes... I paid lots of money.
I was like, okay, I'm going to try...
I'm going to try, like, some...
Some somethings, right?
And I was like...
I tried a bunch of different outfits and nothing worked.
And I was like, frustrated.
And I...
I was like, okay, well, let me put back my maid uniform on.
And it smelled bad.
But my washing machine broke.
So, I did order a new one.
It comes next week.
So, I will be probably smelly.
But I didn't want to be smelly today.
I know that I look like I'm...
I was like, I'm going to be on theme today.
But also, sorry, I'm not fancy like other YouTubers.
And I could only afford half a dress.
So...
Don't worry about it.
Probably.
I mean...
What does the back look like?
Yeah, I'm ready for school prom.
I'm ready to go to my school dance.
Washing machine reimbursement fund.
No!
No, no.
Yeah.
Yay!
I'm ready to dance.
But...
Also, I...
More importantly, we're here to sing.
Don't look.
Don't look, okay?
I'm so...
Thank you for all the gifts you guys.
Thank you.
So, I don't even have my maid headband on today.
It's serious business.
Red super for a red dress.
Thank you!
Sorry, I'm not fancy like other YouTubers.
I don't know how they change clothes.
And then, my mama.
I love her, but she's very busy.
So, sorry that...
I don't have a new outfit or anything to present to you guys.
So...
And I won't have one for a while.
My mama is so busy.
Papa is so busy.
Everybody is so busy.
But that just makes maybe the wait a little bit more worth it.
So, maybe.
Maybe.
For now, I can give you a PNG dress.
You can't see the fishing wire that's like wrapped around my neck.
You know, holding it up.
It's like a piece of cardboard basically.
Just over top of me.
You know?
Yeah.
It's blurry?
Yeah, I just printed it out.
What do you mean?
Are you?
Am I what?
Takanashi Kiara.
Hololive EN myth.
Do you have much to say?
I've seen your thumbnails.
Also, I've seen your outfits.
What would you like to know?
What would you...
What are you...
What are we asking?
Am I not able to afford a new outfit?
Maybe.
I don't know.
No, I can afford one.
I tried buying lots of different ones and none of them worked.
Also, thank you for the other Akazupa!
I love Frillless Friday.
This is the only time you'll see this.
It's special for today.
So I can distract you while I mess up singing.
You can be distracted by...
Is this safe?
Yeah!
Right?
It's safe!
I'm wearing a dress!
If you move too much to the side, could there be an oopsie?
No!
No, no, no.
I checked.
I've checked a lot of times.
I've done this.
I think I was okay.
Actually, I couldn't see when I did it.
I think it's fine.
This is super cute.
You can't see, it's okay.
Anyway...
Don't worry about it.
I didn't distract you guys from my horrible singing.
Because I asked everybody...
Well, I asked memboos.
I said, what jazz songs would you like to hear?
Kiwara.
She's so cute.
I asked what songs you guys would like to sing.
And I got a whole lot of recommendations.
And some of them I wanted to sing, but I couldn't find karaoke versions of them.
And a lot of those songs I did not know.
So...
I learned a bunch of new songs for today.
And I've been putting them on repeat for the past...
All day today.
So I'm nervous that I'm going to mess them up.
I'm really nervous.
But today is a smooth jazz.
I feel like this dress also fits the vibes.
Today is a smooth jazz day.
So you can feel cool and relaxed.
And you can have...
What do you drink at a bar?
I have orange juice.
You can have whiskey.
And feel fancy.
Like you are in a real...
Gin and tonic.
Like you are at a bar.
And you are like...
It's just background noise.
The singing, you know?
So...
Don't pay much attention.
Can you tell I'm nervous?
Oh gosh, okay.
Okey dokey.
Shake and not stir.
Naked and afraid.
What's that saying?
If you are naked...
You will...
Wait, no.
If you are...
In your underwear, you will forget why you were embarrassed to begin with.
Right?
That's...
That's the mindset here.
Like if you do a public speaking in your underwear...
Then you will forget why you were nervous to do the public speaking.
In the first place.
Yes, yes, yes.
You like jazz?
Yeah.
So today is jazzy.
I'm so nervous.
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, is there so much pressure when I do like a themed karaoke?
Especially I think like this where it's like feels so...
So serious.
It's like such serious...
I feel like I have to be extra cool.
Oh gosh, but I'm not extra cool.
I'm wearing a cardboard.
Okay, but we got this.
Probably.
Maybe.
Okay, let me take a sippy and then we'll start.
In today's set list, I actually have been taking some things out.
I might take some more things out depending on how I feel.
But...
It's a little bit shorter than my usual streams because I couldn't learn so much.
And also because...
Because...
What was I going to say?
I wanted to raid Doki for her anniversary.
Yeah, if you were going to plan on watching that, we will raid her.
It should be done before then.
Oh my gosh, Jenny Bravo!
Okay.
Okey dokey.
The song I've sung before, but most of the songs...
Let's see.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9 songs I've never sung before on karaoke.
I had to learn them for this stream.
I had to learn them better.
If I sing them incorrectly, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Alright, but the first song...
It's just like a warm-up.
It's just a warm-up.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm also going to...
I'm also going to be adjusting the volume, so...
Yeah.
Oh!
Who the hell is that?
Oh my gosh, sorry.
Stranger Danger!
Stranger Danger.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here we go.
Notice how I get quiet when there's no one else around You and me in awkward silence Don't you dare look at me that way I don't need reminders of how you don't feel the same Oh, the burning pain Listening to you harp on about some new soulmate She's so perfect,
blah blah blah blah How I wish you'll wake up one day Run to me, confess your love At least just let me say That when I talk to you Oh, Cupid walks right through And shoots an arrow through my heart And I sound like a fool But don't you fail it to confess I loved you from the start
What's a girl to do?
Lying in my bed, staring into the blue.
Unrequited, terrifying love is driving me a bit insane.
Have to get this off my chest, I'm telling you today.
That when I talk to you, a Cupid walks right through and shoots an arrow through my heart.
And I sound like a fool, but don't you feel it to confess I've loved you from the start.
Confess I loved you, just thinking of you.
Loved you from the start.
Yay!
Oh, wait.
Set list, set list.
Okay, that was from the start.
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee.
I'm so nervous.
Oh gosh, I'm like worried about if I'm gonna be able to do these songs properly.
Here, let's do another one that I know before I hit up the ones that I don't know.
What am I doing this one?
Oh, hold on, I have to adjust it.
There we go.
Okay, everybody knows this one, but of course people requested it.
But of course it's a song that has to be sung during a jazzy karaoke I feel, right?
Probably, I think so.
I think so.
Okay, here we go.
Why doesn't it want to play?
Hello?
What's happening?
Okay, restart.
Let me see what spring is like On Jupiter and Mars In other words Hold my hand,
kiss me
Fill my heart with song And let me sing forevermore You are all I long for All I worship and adore
Please be true.
In other words, I love
you.
Feel my
love.
You are all I
worship and adore.
In other
words, Please be true.
Yay!
Fly me to the moon.
Mon.
I forgot to mention that some of these songs might have like, because they're jazzy, you know, they might have a longer instrumental break in between it, you know.
But I don't plan on like talking so much between it because I want you to enjoy the music a little bit.
So if it's just kind of like me vibing, then it's me vibing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you guys for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I don't have so much time.
I want to make sure I get through the whole set list.
So, sorry if I don't respond so much.
But I'm... yeah.
I'm still reading them!
Everybody has a happy birthday!
Actually, let's do like a...
Oh wait, I wonder if there's like a happy birthday that I can sing for everybody whose birthday it is today.
Maybe a happy birthday jazz.
I'm gonna look that up.
Happy birthday songs.
Rock version.
Okay, I'll just do like a...
I'll do like a...
Like a...
A jazzy version.
Okay, not the Marilyn Monroe.
No!
Mr. President.
I'm too embarrassed to do an acapella though.
So I'll just sing to everybody whose birthday it is.
Happy birthday to you.
I'm too embarrassed!
With the music, it's too embarrassing otherwise.
I wish I was born in February.
Just replay it when it's your birthday, I guess.
I don't know.
Okay, let's... we did some slower songs.
Let's do a...
Let's do a faster one.
A lot of people requested this one, I think because it's in Fallout.
A couple of songs are in Fallout that I chose.
And then there might be some other songs that I chose that you're like...
What the heck?
So hopefully it's a kind of interesting...
Oops, sorry.
Interesting set list.
But this one was pretty fun to do.
So let's do...
Okay.
Sorry I'm not taking requests today since I have my set list.
But thank you.
Okay.
I have to up this one.
Three.
I hugged her and she hugged back.
Beautiful, left the sunshine enough to spread.
It's just like the fella said.
Tell me quick, ain't love a kick in the head?
Like the fella once said, ain't love a kick in the head?
Like the sailor said, ain't that a hole in the boat?
My head keeps spinning, I go to sleep and keep grinning.
If this is just the beginning, my life is gonna be beautiful.
She's telling me we'll be wed, she's picked out a king-size bed.
I couldn't feel any better or I'd be sick.
Tell me quick, oh, ain't love a kick?
Tell me quick, ain't love a kick in the head?
Maybe I should have changed the key on that one.
Oh well, it's fine.
Ain't that a kick in the head?
Yeah.
Let's do another one.
I know this one too.
Maybe I should do some other ones that I don't know though.
Yeah, I'll do this one.
This one has a really long instrumental.
It's not much singing, so I apologize.
But I think you guys can still vibe with it.
So we'll just vibe.
I fall in love too easily.
I fall in love too fast.
I fall in love too terribly hard.
For love to ever
should be well-schooled.
Cause I've been fooled in the past.
But still I fall in love so easily.
I fall in love too fast.
I fall in love too terribly hard.
For love to ever should be well-schooled.
Cause I've been fooled in the past.
My
heart should be well-schooled.
Cause I've been fooled in the past.
But still I fall in love too easily.
I fall in love too fast.
The vibes.
The vibes are so good.
I fall in love too fast.
So many I love songs in this list.
Because I think maybe lots of jazz songs are love songs.
But also it's close to Valentine's Day.
Yeah, almost Valentine's.
Yeah, you can just be like I'm so sophisticated and I go to jazz club for Valentine's Day.
You know?
We'll do this one but I'm kind of nervous about it.
Sorry also if I'm singing these wrong.
I feel like I am but whatever.
I'm so nervous.
I'm so nervous still.
Next one probably a lot of people know also.
Stars shining bright above you.
Night breezes seem to whisper I love you.
Birds singing in the sycamore tree.
Dream a little dream of me.
Say nighty night and kiss me.
Just hold me tight and tell me you miss me.
While I'm alone and blue as can be.
Dream a little dream of me.
Stars fading but I linger on dear.
Still craving your kiss.
I'm longing to linger till dawn dear.
Just saying this.
Sweet dreams till sunbeams find you.
Sweet dreams that leave all worries behind you.
But in your dreams whatever they be.
Dream a little dream of me.
Stars fading but I linger on dear.
Still craving your kiss.
I'm longing to linger till dawn dear.
Just saying this.
Sweet dreams till sunbeams find you.
Sweet dreams that leave all worries behind you.
But in your dreams whatever they be.
Dream a little dream of me.
Sorry, I know she goes up an octave at that last part and then I was like wait I can't find the notes again.
Sorry, that was dream a little dream of me.
I knew that song but learning it fully was definitely different.
Okay, let's do another Ella Fitzgerald song.
Actually, this might be my last Ella Fitzgerald song.
But I've done this one before on stream.
Look
at me.
I'm as helpless as a kitten up a tree.
And I feel like I'm clinging to a cloud.
I can't understand.
I get misty just holding your hand.
And a thousand violins begin to play.
Or it might be the sound of your hello.
That music I hear.
I get misty the moment you're near.
Can't you see that you're leading me on?
And it's just what I want.
Don't you notice how hopelessly I'm lost?
That's why I'm following you.
Would I wander through this wonderland alone?
Never knowing my right foot from my left, my hand.
I'm too misty and too much in love.
Too misty and
in love.
Oops.
My voice.
I was like suppressing a yawn.
Because when I sing like this, you know, I have to open my throat so much.
And it makes me want to yawn a lot.
So I was suppressing a yawn of that too misty.
So it made my voice crack.
Let's do this.
These ones are more modern songs.
Hold on, hold on.
Thank you guys for all the gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Actually, I only listened... I was only able to practice this one like two times.
If I mess up some of the parts, I'm sorry.
I'm doing alright on time.
Maybe I feel like I'm rushing through this.
I think I'm just trying to get the nerves out.
Thank you, thank you.
What does that mean?
Stop the pause.
I think I'm sorry.
I feel so much pressure.
OK.
OK, OK.
So this one will be kind of fun to sing maybe.
You should wear a warning It's dangerous I'm falling
There's no escape I can't wait I need a hit Baby give me it You're dangerous I love men Too
high, can't come down Who's in my head, spinning round and round
Now the taste of your lips, I'm on a ride You're toxic, I'm slipping under The taste of a poison paradise I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic
It's getting late to give you up I took a sip from the devil's cup Slowly, it's taking over me
It's in the air, and it's all around Can you feel me now?
The taste of your lips, I'm on a ride You're toxic, I'm slipping under The taste of a poison paradise I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic And I love what you do, don't you know that you're toxic
The taste of your lips, I'm on a ride You're toxic, I'm slipping under The taste of a poison paradise I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic Intoxicate me now, with your loving mouth I think I'm ready now, I think I'm ready now Intoxicate me now,
with your loving I'm addicted to you, don't you know that you're toxic
Which I have another one by them.
Apparently they do a lot of songs Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Shake it out the nerve, shake it out the nerve I'll do the next one because I don't think I actually got to practice this one at all What do you mean yes?
Thank you guys!
Thank you for all the superchats!
Thank you, thank you, thank you Wear your clothes, I'm wearing a dress!
What are you talking about?
Let me do that real quick, I'm just going to have them not pop up, I'm really sorry I do see your notifications, thank you guys so so much, I really appreciate it I just saw one, you guys are so depraved You are so depraved
Entry ticket, no!
It's free!
Yeah, postmodern jukebox.
This one also, I saw someone request this one and I was like oh this might be fun Because I was thinking, oh wait I was thinking of this song not too long ago
I didn't practice this at all, so sorry Sorry if it sounds weird.
Let's go!
When the bee stings, when I'm feeling sad I simply remember my favorite things And then I don't feel so bad Raindrops on roses and whiskers on kittens Bright copper candles and warm woolen mittens Brown paper packages tied up with strings These are a few of my favorite things Cream colored ponies and crisp apple strudels Doorbells and sleigh bells and schnitzel with doodles Wild geese that fly with the moon on their wings.
These are a few of my favorite things.
Girls in white dresses with blue satin sashes.
Snowflakes that stay on my nose and eyelashes.
Silver white winters that melt into springs.
These are a few of my favorite things.
Cream-colored ponies and crisp apple strudels.
Doorbells and sleigh bells and schnitzel with noodles.
Wild geese that fly with the moon on their wings.
These are a few of my favorite things.
Girls in white dresses with blue satin sashes.
Snowflakes that stay on my nose and eyelashes.
Silver white winters that melt into springs.
These are a few of my favorite things.
When the dog bites, when the bee stings, when I'm feeling sad.
I simply remember my favorite things and then I don't feel so bad.
Sorry, I tripped over my words.
My favorite things.
Postmodern jukebox version.
Actually, I only have a few songs left.
Maybe I should slow down.
Well, some of them are like kind of short songs, you know, and some of them are longer.
The next song, I usually don't sing the full version, but maybe we can sing...
Well, it's not singing, it's instrumental.
Never slow down.
And more songs.
I don't know so many.
I had to learn a lot of these and I'm still nervous about the few that I have.
I'm still nervous about them.
I'll sing this next song.
Hold on, let me pull it up.
Actually, I don't think this one is on Kara-fun, let me see.
Or maybe it was.
No, it's not.
I have to pull it up.
Ghost in red dresses.
I don't think red suits me so much, but I felt like it's such a jazz bar dress, right?
I feel.
I had another pink dress that I was going to try wearing instead, but...
It actually showed even more, so...
I was like...
I really tried lots of different stuff, but nothing worked on me.
Lots of different outfits.
I wanted to actually wear something really nice.
I was like, I don't know.
I was like...
For those who are just like, oh, she keeps talking about new outfits.
There is one coming eventually, but it will still be quite some time from now.
So, you know.
I was like...
Maybe in the meantime...
I could try something like this.
But it's kind of back...
Not backpedal.
What's the word?
It backfired on me.
Yeah.
I...
I probably won't do this again.
Hold on, let me check if this is okay.
Yeah.
Okay, it seems like to be good.
I might have to turn the volume.
Of course I have to sing this song if we are singing jazz.
I actually tried to find an instrumental of the song that plays at the end of Metal Gear Solid 3.
When Snake and Eva are having times in the cabin.
But there is no instrumental of it anywhere, so I have to commission one.
If I ever...
If I do this again.
Well, I can always sing it whenever.
It doesn't have to be a jazzy...
It doesn't have to be a jazzy stream, probably.
But...
Yeah, there is no instrumental, right?
It sucks.
But of course, there is an instrumental of this song from Metal Gear Solid 2.
Let's go.
I just realized you can't hear it.
There we go.
And think, what am I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt and pained?
Or am I filled with love?
I walk by myself on the streets below And ask every child I know Do you think tomorrow will bring sun or rain?
Which one of these will show?
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend I keep holding on till the end Out of the darkness, there is no other way Than the light leading to yesterday
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war And dreams that I let slip away I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for Way back in yesterday
Why can't each of us in the world ever see the best things in life are free?
Little sounds of laughter, a warm hug, a smile, a kiss from you to me.
I fall to my knees, I cry and I cry.
Love, do not pass me by.
Happy ever after, please stay for a while.
Make time, refuse to fly.
I can't say goodbye to yesterday, my friend.
Cause I know how good it has been.
Facing forever, here I stand, come what may.
In the old, in the new, yesterday.
It's there that I'll find inner peace, not war and dreams that I let slip away.
I will find the joyfulness I'm looking for, way back in yesterday.
Yay, two minute outro.
I feel like a Bond villain wearing this.
You know, the eyepatch with the dress, I feel like a Bond villain.
Shaken, not stirred.
And then
my hammer space, I reach behind my shoulders and I grab it.
Don't female Bond villains all end up naked?
I
have one of those.
Too much!
No, thank you!
And there's our outro.
Yay!
No, Mr. Wisp, I expect you to die.
That was...
Can't say goodbye to yesterday, which I've sung many, many times on stream, I feel.
One, two, three, four.
I have four songs left.
Four songs left.
Your voice has elevated my soul.
I can get rid of this now.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
The next couple of songs...
Wait.
All the rest of the songs I've never sung before.
So I'm very nervous.
Hydrate?
I have been.
I have some water.
Well, I have tea, actually.
I'm trying to decide what order I do them in.
Can we request more songs?
There's probably so many that I don't know, though, you know?
There's probably so many I would probably...
Most of them I'd be like, sorry, I don't know, sorry, I don't know, sorry.
Sorry, I don't know, sorry, I don't know, sorry, I don't know.
Creep is not a jazz song.
Jazz songs only.
Actually, I think this next one that I'll do is not entirely jazz.
But I saw someone request it and I was like, oh!
I think this one could be fun to learn.
And surprisingly enough, Kerafun had it.
So...
I think many people maybe will be surprised by this one.
And also that I'm singing it.
There's a jazz version?
I wish there was a jazz version of Break Stuff.
How does it start?
It's just one of those days when you don't want to wake up.
Everybody sucks.
Wait, no.
Everything fucks.
Wait, how does it go?
Everybody sucks.
Oh, everything sucks.
I can't remember it.
Everybody sucks.
I made up the tune.
I feel like the words would just ruin the vibe though.
It's all about the he says, she says bullshit.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, this next song is from another video game.
Video game.
Video game!
Okay.
Everything fucks.
Sorry, I've never played this series so...
You can call me a fake fan for sure.
Well, I'm not claiming to be a fan.
I'm just claiming to sing the song.
And I'll try my best.
Where have I been?
I'm a shapeshifter I pose masquerade Hiding both face and mind All free for you to draw I'm a shapeshifter What else should I be?
Please don't take off my mask Revealing dark
Moments of calm Nothing left to be found A mirror right in front of me That's where I find An empty glass Reflecting the sad truth It's telling words not to be told I need the mask I'm a shapeshifter I pose masquerade, hiding both face and mind.
All free for you to draw.
I'm a shapeshifter, chained down to my core.
Please don't take off my mask, my place to hide.
Oh,
I forgot this part, I'm sorry.
I just learned this song today, I'm sorry.
Is that the good sign?
Unleash me, I'm burning the walls.
Is there a way for me to break?
I'm a shapeshifter, I pose masquerade.
Hiding both face and mind.
All free for you to draw.
I'm a shapeshifter, I have no face to show.
Please don't take off my mask, my disguise.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Hold on, I'm gonna go back to that part and listen how it goes.
I really learned this one today, so I apologize.
Hold on, I'm going back to that part.
How's it go?
How's this part go?
I can't tell you how to see me.
Just a cage of bones, there's nothing inside.
Unleash me, burning down the walls.
Is there a way for me to break?
Shoot.
It kind of came to me, your singing is so beautiful.
Thank you!
Shoot.
Shoot, shoot.
Oh well.
Maybe I will sing this again someday.
I'll learn it better.
As a Phantom Thief, I'm obligated to say the Persona series is great.
Yeah, I borrowed Persona 4 from a friend a long long time ago and I never had a chance to play it.
Well, I played a little bit of it, but I never got a chance to finish it.
And by play a little bit, I mean like not a lot at all.
But I know so many people like P5.
Persona 5!
I didn't mean to say PP!
So, yeah.
Okay, PP.
No!
No, I was trying to say P5, but then I was like my brain was conflicting with saying P5.
P5 and Persona 5.
Oh, my brain.
What's wrong with PP?
Yeah, no.
Okay.
I still don't feel so relaxed.
Why did I say I was going to do this?
Well, so many people seem to like the Santa baby.
And I was like, well, maybe a jazz themed karaoke would be kind of fun and it would make me learn a bunch of new songs.
But, oh gosh, I feel too anxious.
I think I, like I said, it's too much pressure when it's something that is like themed like this.
So, unless it's, I don't know, it's just so much pressure.
I'm creating my own pressure.
No pressure.
For singing one of my favorite Persona songs, I must kneel.
Well, you can thank the membu who wrote it on the suggestion post.
Yeah, so, and of course, you know, for future streams, I mean, I always, people are always sending me suggestions anyway.
But maybe, maybe for the, if I do another jazz karaoke, I can do more of the people's suggestions.
There were some, I had my, my initial set list was 20 songs, like usually, like I usually have.
And I had to cut it down a whole bunch because I couldn't learn enough songs in time.
So I apologize.
Jazz Revengeance, maybe.
Maybe, maybe.
Yes, yes, yes.
Last three, I'm still nervous about, I'm so nervous.
Okay, I'm going to do this next one.
Can you hear me typing?
This one I have to, hold on.
Okay, okay.
I remember how it goes, I think.
I think, oh, I don't know.
We'll see.
Hold on, let me hear the, let me hear the first key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay.
Still impressed you learned so much in such a short time.
Jazz is hard, but you're blowing it out of the water.
Thank you.
Okie dokie.
Okay.
I like the song a lot, actually.
From when I was learning it, I was like, this song is so cute.
Okay.
These foolish things remind me of you.
A tinkling piano in the next apartment.
Those stumbling words that told you what my heart meant.
A fairgrounds painted swings.
These foolish things remind me of you.
You came, you saw, you conquered me.
When you did that to me, I knew somehow this had to be.
The winds of March that made my heart a dancer.
The telephone that rings, but who was phoned?
Oh, how the ghost of you clings.
These foolish things remind me of you.
First daffodils and long excited cables.
And candle lights on little corner tables.
And still my heart has wings.
These foolish things remind me of you.
The park at evening when the bell has sounded.
The Ile de France with all the girls around it.
The beauty that is spring.
These foolish things remind me of you.
How strange, how sweet to find you still.
These things are dear to me.
They seem to bring you near to me.
The sigh of midnight trains and empty stations.
Silk stockings thrown aside, dance invitations.
Oh, how the ghost of you clings.
These foolish things remind me of you.
Oh, these foolish things remind me of...
Yay!
I forgot a little bit of the middle there, sorry.
These foolish things...
Yay!
How the ghost of you clings!
I'm the ghost.
And I'm clinging to your life force.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
Such a cute song though, right?
Okay!
Yay!
Just karaoke but no bebop cowboy?
I couldn't remember enough.
I only know the ending.
Like what?
Like the real folk blues?
Lots of blues.
Right!
It still counts?
Does it?
I don't remember enough of the song I think.
I think I only know the ending version.
I don't know the middle version of it.
Tank is jazz?
Tank has like...
Hey everybody, let's get this party started.
It's time to play the song Tank.
I wonder if they have it on here.
Oh wait, I think... No, they do not.
That would be crazy though.
They do have the real folk blues on here which I also thought was...
Which I also thought was really crazy.
Someone did request it and I like tried...
Oh no, wait!
They have a TV size!
Amari ni mo toki wa sugitte shimatta Mada kokoro no kokorobi wo Iyasenu mama kaze ga fuite
Kawaita hitomi de dareka naite kure
Oh, I cut out so abruptly.
I didn't even finish drinking my tea.
Yay, impromptu, the real folk blues.
Now, I only sang that one because I initially had it on my set list, but I took it out because I was like, I don't know the full version and I don't have time to learn it.
And it's technically not really jazzy.
I mean, well, it's jazzy, but you know what I mean.
It works.
Probably.
How do I want to do this next song?
I had something that I wanted to do for this next song.
The version that I learned from I Don't Feel is very jazzy, even though it's a jazzy song, but I felt all jazzy songs or versions of this song were...
Were...
City of Space Minto.
Were in French.
And I think I might have practiced this song the most today because I was like, I don't know French.
I don't know French.
I do not know.
So, oh gosh.
But I really tried to try singing French.
I don't know.
I'm going to pronounce things wrong and you guys will be like, oh, no, no, no.
And...
And what's worse is I took three years of French and my last name is French.
Phantom!
But I don't know.
I don't know at all.
All I remember how to say in French is c'est dgotant, which is disgusting.
And a va?
Oui, a va.
And qu'est-ce que c'est?
And omelette de fromage.
I know that one too.
Thank you Metal Gear.
It's not mint fantomy.
Mint fantomy.
Oh, Les Miserables.
I
don't think I can do the whole... I didn't also really learn the beginning of the song.
Je t'aime.
Oui.
Non, non, non, non.
Non, je t'aime.
Non, non, non.
Non, non.
Do it for practice.
If it sounds so bad, I will unarchive this.
I'm too embarrassed.
Non,
non, non, non, non.
Please, no.
Ah, oh.
Okay.
Maybe I'll just do my... Hold on, let me listen to the beginning of this.
Sorry, let me listen to the beginning of this version.
Because this one I really like because it's so jazzy, but...
Oh, I can't do this.
I'm gonna... I feel like I'm gonna be sounding like I'm making a mockery.
There's an English version.
Yeah, I know.
I had another English version too.
It just didn't sound... The Louis Armstrong version is too much instrumental.
I had another one.
But the other one that I had didn't sound so jazzy.
So I was like, okay, maybe I can try the Lady Gaga one.
Because I didn't know that she sang it.
I've never seen A Star is Born, but she apparently sang it in that.
The Frenchies can take it.
Don't speak for them!
I'm so sorry.
I had this in the middle of my setlist and I kept pushing it off and off and off and off.
I kept pushing it off and off and off and off.
Because I was like, I'm too nervous to sing it yet.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, don't make fun of me.
Okay, guys, or I'll never sing again.
I'll never sing again.
You'll never see me.
You'll never see me alive.
Because you know what?
Because I'm not alive.
I think Tia will give you a pass.
Okay.
Maybe.
Anybody who's French, I'm trying.
Oh, God, I feel like I'm about to cry.
Oh, God.
I'm not strong enough.
I cry when I'm embarrassed.
Sorry.
Okay.
Okay, the French are kind people.
Maybe I'll just do... You know what?
Let me sing the English version.
English version first.
Is that okay?
I'm going to try the English version.
Sorry that this one isn't as jazzy sounding.
I apologize.
Oh, wait.
I need to change the key.
Yes, I do.
Good thing I checked.
Sorry, I'm checking everything real quick.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
This is
When you kiss me heaven's eyes, and though I close my eyes, I see love in a rose.
When you press your heart, I'm in a world apart.
A world where roses bloom.
And when you speak, angels sing from above.
Everyday words seem to turn into love songs.
Give your heart and soul to me, and life will always be love in a rose.
Sorry, I chickened out.
I chickened out.
I was like, okay, I'm gonna sing here.
Maybe if I sing along with Lady Gaga, I'll feel better.
Let me sing with Lady Gaga.
Lady Gaga, help me.
Help me, Lady Gaga.
Help me.
Help me, Lady.
Oh There are some things that make me feel good But nothing comes out of my mouth Here are the words that touch me From my heart, I'm going to tell you When you take me in your arms I'm going to fall down I see life in a rose He tells me words of me Words of everyday And it makes me feel good
Oh, the timing!
What is this pacing?
Why did she say, would anybody like some French tips tonight?
I don't get it.
Sorry, I forgot the last part.
I tried, okay?
Now you can't say that I didn't try.
Now you can't say that I didn't try!
Thank you Lady Gaga for back up vocals.
I called in a favor for her.
I was like, Lady Gaga, please.
Lady Gaga, you know how you owe me.
She was just returning the favor, right?
J'adore.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
C'est magnifique.
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
Merci, merci, merci beaucoup.
Yay!
Alright guys, it's time for my finale song.
Which isn't, I guess, maybe so much great.
In fact, I don't know why I kept this one as the finale song.
Because the karaoke version that I have of it is not very good at all.
It's not very good at all.
Maybe we'll do Snake Eater as the finale finale.
Okay, I'll sing this song and then we'll sing Snake Eater.
Since I feel that maybe the karaoke that I have of this kind of sucks.
Because there was no karaoke that I could find anywhere.
Sounds French to me.
Greetings from Germany.
Thank you.
Jazzy Snake Eater.
I don't know if there is.
Oh wait, there is.
There is a jazz version of Snake Eater, but I don't think it has an instrumental.
Okay, hold on.
I have to remember how this song goes.
I apologize in advance for the karaoke quality of this song, but I really did want to sing it regardless.
I apologize.
Okay.
Happy birthday!
Is that a real birthday?
I think this one is also from Fallout.
Holy loud, I'm so sorry.
My goodness gracious.
Okay, what were we doing?
Sorry, so sorry.
My ears.
Take me, make me forget my sorrow.
So when I wake tomorrow, I'll know our love was right.
Kiss me as though it were now or never.
Teach me all that a heart should know.
Love me as though there were no tomorrow.
Don't ever let me go.
As though there were no tomorrow.
Love me.
Don't ever let me go.
Love me as though there was no tomorrow.
Such a pretty song.
Pretty, pretty, pretty.
Okay, I guess we finish with... Yay!
Thank you for the jazzy vibes!
Thank you!
Hold on, I think it's this one.
Let me double check.
Let me also make sure.
Hold on.
I think this is okay.
I think this works.
I think this is good.
Okay, so I did say what a thrill, so... Sneeter time!
Oh, don't forget the eyepatch!
So true!
So true, so true, so true, so true, so true.
Okay, okay.
Alrighty, alrighty.
Let's go.
What
a thrill.
With darkness and silence through the night.
What a thrill.
I'm searching and I'm melting to you.
What a fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
I'd give my life for
you.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
It's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, sneaking up.
Someday you'll go through the rain.
Someday you'll feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal, the trial to survive.
For the day we see new light.
I'd give my life, not for honor, but for you.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, sneaking up.
Sneaking up.
I'll show you guys my dress off one last time.
Say goodbye to the dress, say goodbye to the dress.
I'm teeny tiny.
I hope you guys liked the karaoke.
Thanks for jazzy jazz fun time.
See you guys later.
Otsumindo.
Bye JPEG dress.
Yeah, bye JPEG dress.
Bye bye.
Otsumindo.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank
you guys, thank you.